We'll now take a quick look at the other three qualities and
their effect on pipe and filter.
For reliability, okay, the reliability of a pipe and
filter system may be reduced because, the reliability of
an overall system is only as good as its weakest, weakest link.
That is, if any of the filters in the pipeline or if any of the pipes break down
for some reason, the whole application breaks down.
Safety may also be reduced because of the multiple dependencies.
On the other hand,
it's easier to verify because all of the output comes from a single source.
Security benefits because of the simplicity of
the architecture increases opportunities for
authentication, encryption and implementation of security levels.